الى سودان حيث ذكرت مصادر ومحليه عن
انفجارا هزه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم صباح
اليوم وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في المكان دون
ان تتسنى
للمتابعين معرفه ملابساته هذا وقد رصد
مراسل الجزيره بجنوب الخرطوم وقوع
اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
بالاسلحه الثقيله
انضم الينا الان منهم درماننا مراسله
الجزيره هيثم ما ارحب بك اخر التطورات
لديك
نعم ميدانيا كانت هناك تسمع اصوات
لانفجارات في منطقه وسط الخرطوم
على اثري ذلك تتصاعد الاعمده الدخان من
هذه المنطقه بكثافه في هذه اللحظات وايضا
صباح اليوم كانت هناك اصوات الاشتباكات في
منطقه الجنوب الخرطوم في المنطقه الجنوبيه
في المؤديه الى الطريق الى ولايه النيل
الابيض في الطريقه الجزء الجنوبي من
الخرطوم هذه المناطق اليوم شهدت هذه
الاشتباكات وهذه المعركه كانت تدور في تلك
المنطقه بحسب مصادر المحليه قوه بالقوات
الدعم السريه كانت تحاول مهاجمه مقر قياده
الاحتياطي المركزي للشرطه في تلك المنطقه
وان الطيران الحربي قام بالتدخل في تلك
المنطقه واجبر هذه القوات على التراجع
بحسب المصادر المحليه هناك ولكن عدا ذلك
الاوضاع التظل هذه الصباح اليوم على عكس
الايام الماضيه هذه الاشتباكات المتواصله
في الشهر الثاني في وذلك يعني اعلن
المفوضيه الشؤون اللاجئين بالامم المتحده
ان النازحين جراء هذه الاشتباكات تجاوز
المليون شخص من المناطق المختلفه للنزاع
وبالتالي الان الكلفه الانسانيه والتبعات
الانسانيه تفاقمت اذا هذه الاوضاع وطلبت
بالضروره دعم المتاثرين وايصال المساعدات
الغذائيه العاجله لهم والصحيه ايضا كذلك
في ظل التزايد هذا العنف في المناطق سواء
كانت في داخل الخرطوم او في المناطق او في
ولايه دارفور التي تشهد ايضا النزاعات
طبعا ياتي ذلك في وقت ما تزال فيه
المحادثات غير المباشره التجري في جده
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه ولكن حتى الان
لم يعني ترشح انباء عن توقيع اتفاق
النهائي رغم ان هناك مصادر تحدثت عن ان
هناك ربما تقترب الاطراف الان من توقيع
هدنه حقيقيه يتم بموجبها ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين بحسب
ما اعلنه اعلان جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اشكرك هيثم كنت معنا من ام درمان